locke du jour appelle la question orale
de madame sophie primas à madame la
ministre de l'égalité des territoires du
logement fha parole mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chaque collègue cette question
s'adresse c'est bien sûr à madame duflot
notamment sa qualité de ministre de
l'égalité des territoires je souhaite en
effet attiré l'attention du gouvernement
sur la nécessité de la réforme de la
taxe annuelle sur les locaux à usage de
bureaux les locaux commerciaux et les
locaux de stockage qui est perçu dans la
région ile de france et dont la refonte
avait pour objectif de participer au
financement du réseau de transport
public du grand paris en 2011
l'accroissement de cette taxe sur les
bureaux a été évalué à 65 % + 65 % sur
l'ensemble de la région avec des
progressions extrêmement différenciée
selon les départements français ainsi
franciliens pardon entre 2010 et 2011
cette taxe a augmenté de 180 % dans mon
bon département des yvelines et 2 176%
dans le val d'oise tandis qu'elle ne
s'est accru que de 41% en seine saint
denis et de 58% à paris
cet écart soulève naturellement la
question de la pertinence du zonage sur
lequel se fonde cette imposition
d'autant plus que ce zonage ne
correspond pas à la qualité de la
desserte par les transports en commun
les entreprises qui contribuent le plus
sont situées dans les départements qui
d'ébène qui bénéficierait le moins des
avantages du grand paris ainsi dans la
partie grant west des yvelines dans le
mantois territoire dans lequel le taux
de chômage est parmi les plus élevés de
l'île de france en raison notamment des
soucis d'industrialisation de
l'automobile le développement économique
est entravée par le niveau de taxe
équivalant à la charge foncière dans un
contexte de vives tensions sur le marché
de l'immobilier d'entreprise et sur le
marché de l'emploi il serait donc
particulièrement pertinent de réviser ce
zonage afin que l'imposition prenne en
compte la réalité économique du
territoire et présentent réellement une
contrepartie notables en termes
d'équipement réel ou de perspective
rapide d'amélioration du service de
transport en ce sens suite à la
mobilisation de monsieur yves vandewalle
d'alors député des yvelines le préfet de
la région ile-de-france avait mis en
place un groupe ii travail sur le zonage
ce groupe a publié un rapport en juillet
2012 qui analysent notables notamment la
possibilité d'asseoir la taxe sur les
bureaux sur les loyers et sur les
valeurs locatives
il serait donc souhaitable en plus que
nous nous interrogions sur la pertinence
même du maintien à de tels niveaux de
cette taxe voire de son augmentation
alors que le gouvernement semble se
démobiliser sur une partie du grand
paris des transports notamment en
renonçant à inscrire dans la loi de
programmation le milliard d'euros
nécessaires à la poursuite du projet
dans sa totalité
dans un tel contexte il part
injustifiable de gréve et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
installées en grande couronne sans aucun
espoir d'attractivité supplémentaire à
court terme par conséquent je
souhaiterais avoir votre position et
celle du gouvernement d'une part sur la
pertinence du maintien de cette taxe à
de tels taux et d'autre part sur les
suites qui seront données aux
conclusions du rapport du groupe de
travail sur le zonage je vous remercie
beaucoup merci mes chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur pascal canfin mini
chargé du développement vous devez la
parole monsieur ministre la sénatrice je
vous prie de renouveler lexus concernant
l'absence de cécile duflot retenu à
l'assemblée vous avez bien voulu attirer
son attention sur des dispositions des
lois de finances rectificative 2010 2011
qui modifie le zonage et modules
d'étendre la redevance pour création de
locaux de bureaux commerciaux et de
stockage en ile de france vous fait
valoir que les lois apprécie t on induit
des différences géographiques de taux au
sein du périmètre du grand paris
beaucoup plus importante dans les
départements des yvelines et du val
d'oise est nettement plus faible dans
ceux de seine-saint-denis et de paris
vous contester la légitimité de cette
augmentation qui n'est pas destiné à
financer l'amélioration de la desserte
des yvelines par les transports publics
ces arguments appelle les précisions
suivantes la redevance pour création de
locaux de bureaux relevé par définition
la nature d'une taxe fiscale
destinée à financer des infrastructures
de transport public et non pas celle
d'une redevance pour services rendus il
est par conséquent inexact de considérer
que l'importance du taux de cette
redevance devrait être directement
proportionnel aux services rendus en
contrepartie de cette contribution
conformément par ailleurs à la demande
des parlementaires exprimés lors du vote
des lois mentionné à l'instant un groupe
de travail présidé par le préfet de la
région ile de france réunissant des élus
des représentants des entreprises des
services de l'état et des établissements
publics a été mise en place afin de
formuler des propositions sur la manière
de répartir cet axe sur l'ensemble de la
région ile de france le groupe de
travail a déposé ses conclusions en
juillet 2012 ces dernières sont
actuellement en cours d'examen par les
services du ministère de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement plusieurs
pistes ont été dégagées qui seront
examinées avec les collectivités
territoriales notamment bien évidemment
la région ile de france et avec
l'ensemble des partenaires économiques
comme vous le savez enfin le
gouvernement est très attaché à la
réussite du projet de transport à
l'échelle du grand paris dont les
engagements ont été confirmés est
crédibilisée par le premier ministre le
6 mars dernier ces éléments je l'espère
sont de nature à vous rassurer sur le
bien-fondé de l'effort financier du
gouvernement en faveur du grand paris et
de la région ile-de-france
ministre parole de monoprix mode
je vous remercie de cette réponse je
voudrais quand même attirer votre
attention sur effectivement il n'y a pas
de relation de proportionnalité entre la
taxation des entreprises et les
investissements de transport qui sont
fait néanmoins dans notre grand ouest
des yvelines mais c'est vrai aussi dans
le val d'oise il y à de nombreuses
entreprises sur des territoires qui sont
des territoires industriels anciens qui
ont des difficultés aujourd'hui
notamment en raison de la difficulté de
l'industrie automobile qui ont donc
besoin d'un souffle économique et sur
lequel cette redevance le taux de cette
redevance est extrêmement élevé et donc
s'il n'y a pas de proportionnalité c'est
très compliqué d'expliquer aux
entreprises de venir s'installer sur ces
territoires là lorsque la charge de
cette taxe est équivalente à la charge
foncière c'est à dire le prix du mètre
carré c'est le prix il doit être doublé
par le prix de la taxe donc je voudrais
que dans les discussions et dans les
réflexions qui ne manqueront pas de
faire jour dans les prochaines semaines
et que vous m'avez annoncé nous ayons
bien cela en tête dans l'égalité des
territoires et des chances des
populations
qu'ils habitent je vous remercie